the Senate adjourned for its Memorial
Day recess without passing a resolution
to extend the Paycheck protection
program known as PPP the program which
helps small businesses pay employees has
faced significant backlash as many
businesses have been unable to get the
loans so yesterday you may recall we
showed you how minority-owned businesses
in particular are struggling to get
federal assistance billionaire investor
Robert Smith is working with lawmakers
in Washington to change that he's trying
to find a solution he is the CEO and
founder of Vista Equity Partners and
joins us from Denver good morning to you
mr. Smith always good to see you I want
to start right away with the piece from
yesterday because the thing that stuck
out to me was the importance of
relationships relationships
relationships or relationships why is
that so important and why is it so
difficult it seems for minority
businesses to establish the important
relationships with banking the large
banks have actually removed their
branches from these neighborhoods and
there's a statistic around 70% of
african-american neighborhoods actually
don't have a branch bank and so they
don't these businesses 94% of them or so
are small sole proprietorships and so
they don't have those banking
relationships and so it's important that
they think about you know creating
relationships with the the what I call
the capillary banking's and those are
the Community Development financial
institutions of minority depository
institutions which is what we've been
working with with with secretary Minuten
and others to build out some
infrastructure so they can actually
process the PPP loans effectively we've
been actually pretty effective in that
act in that action over the last few
weeks what is unique about minority
businesses it may be different from
others well the vast majority of them
again you said 94% are sole proprietors
they have under five employees and so
when you think about you know the value
of the PPP loan it's you know typically
under $50,000 or so is what they need to
actually frankly you know repair other
businesses during this this this this
time of shutdown and unfortunately the
way that the
the arrangement is built there actually
isn't an economic incentive for large
banks to actually prioritize their loans
and so we've been focused on driving the
capacity for these smaller banks and
capillary banks to process those loans
effectively and profitably you know
there's about a five percent that they
would get on a fight and it cost frankly
more money to process the loans and they
actually get in fees from from the
government and processing the loan so
that's one of the issues if we've been
challenged with yeah you hit on it a
little bit but I want to make sure
people understand because I've heard
from minority businesses look I only
need twenty three thousand dollars I
only need forty thousand dollars and yet
they're giving huge sums of money to
already establish businesses and I think
people are having a hard time with that
disconnect why do they get it and I
don't when I don't need as much right
unfortunately it's basic economics the
larger loans even though they get a
smaller fee it's a quantum of dollars to
the banks that incentivizes them to
prioritize the bigger companies the
bigger loans as opposed to the smaller
ones you know some of the work that we
found with our CDFIs and mb is it takes
about seven and a half hours to prop
without technology to really process
these loans effectively and that cost
them about fifteen hundred dollars to
process the loans they only get you know
again five thousand or five percent on
follows a twenty-five thousand dollar
loan to only receive twelve hundred and
fifty dollars so they're losing money on
every loan so we've been engaging with
everyone have a pocket trump to you know
secretary Minuten to to senator schumer
to think about how can we actually
change that either change the amount or
change the efficiency of the processing
so that incentivizes these banks to
actually go process the smaller loans
which are essential frankly for our
communities so if you know I hear people
say is there any money left even that's
one question and if you've tried if
you've applied for a loan and been
rejected should you keep trying where
should you go so first the interest
there is money left our estimate you can
look at the SBA it's probably you know
somewhere north of seventy billion
dollars left from what we can tell from
at least two days ago
and many of our small to medium
businesses and rural businesses were
getting rejected or heard nothing from
the larger banks that they had either
had relationships with or or that they
went
prepare their loans with and so going to
the CDFI is an effective way and the MDI
is an effective way to to actually get
the loans process and we've been very
effective actually in getting folks who
were either turned down or didn't hear
anything processed I would recommend
people go to national Thank You org
National Action Network net or our fair
share comm and and really go through the
application process is there of course
there's the PayPal's and make and the
squares etc who are isolated with the
process if you have a relationship with
those with those companies but I think
it's important to think about these
capillary banking systems these FinTech
enabled banking systems as an effective
way for small to medium businesses
specifically minority businesses in
rural businesses they actually get
access to the PPP capital all right
Robert spent a year ago this week you
were you you surprised everybody at
Morehouse College you said I'm gonna pay
off your student loans you have a
favorite memory from that day briefly
because you got huge kudos for that it
shocked everybody Bravo to you for that
your favorite memory of the day I think
the favorite memories my mother looked
at me and she said well done son that
was my favorite memory of the day well
done well done son indeed I echo your
mom thank you very much Robert Smith